feliz año para todos a esta hora se
reporta anormalidad en el puerto de
dover en el reino unido- y también en
cali en francia el ingreso a europa han
transitado pocos camiones hasta este
momento quienes ingresen a francia deben
presentar una prueba negativa del
coronavirus pero lo cierto y la gran
prueba de fuego de cómo será toda esta
nueva logística será a partir del lunes
4 de enero que será el gran día cuando
los conductores tendrán que presentar
documentación a incertidumbre porque hay
muchos retos para el primero el primer
ministro el primero de ellos es mantener
el reino unido por un lado de escocia
quiere independizarse y por el otro
irlanda del norte se mantiene en el
mercado común de la unión europea y
además debe demostrarles a quienes
votaron por el bec sido en el 2016 que
este país tendrá riqueza económica tal y
como él lo ha prometido luisa español
donde lograron un principio de acuerdo
para evitar una frontera dura en
gibraltar cuál es la importancia de este
anuncio para la nueva relación comercial
entre las partes
es fundamental porque habrá libre
circulación de ciudadanos gibraltar un
territorio en altamar británico se unirá
al estado schengen además habrá un
régimen aduanero para mercancías y
transporte los detalles serán objetos de
una negociación posterior entre londres
y bruselas quedarse rápidamente además
de otras negociaciones como los
servicios financieros el intercambio de
datos y la economía digital